Now, let me go ahead and return to the notebook.
And we will also see how this appears when we
plot the numbers.
When we plot the vectors.
now I'm going to I've written some created some
functions that allow us to
create
vectors
let me show you one example of
creating a drawing a line on math product because with mathpot lip
the way you draw a line on a plot.
is by creating
a sequence of points
XY points
and then get that gives the
the appearance of there being aligned. So let me show you some simple
example.
First I will create a figure.
and assign
a variable ax to the axes of the figure
by doing this we can set the limits of
the axes.
Set the labels of the axes. So I'll show
you what I mean.
And I'm going so here I'll do just that I'm going
to have this is going to be a two-dimensional example. So this is
get rid of that vectors into the
the x-axis will go from negative 15 to 15.
The y-axis will go from 0 to 10.
So we'll have the two quadrants of the Cartesian system.
Then I'm going to create.
a sequence of points
So again, how do we plot a simple Point? Let's
say we have P1.
and this will be
let's say five and five.
of obviously the order is X and Y always the
case XY and then if there was a third of
Third axis. It will be Z.
And then the plot this point we would go.
It would go.
ax.plot
P1 0 P 1
so P0 will be the point on the x-axis P1
would be the point of the y axis.
Very straightforward. That's what I want to show you.
That's the marker.
and so
in order for us to draw a line from the origin.
To this point we need to create a
sequence of these points.
So something.
to this effect
this would be
let's say
this is the first point.
A second point this is the third point.
And let's just make this two to two five
five.
and seven seven
and I will write this code.
copy this code twice
This will be P2.
This will be P3.
Okay, so we can get a light to go this
way. Now. There are two types of three types of vectors. There
are.
position vectors
That can appear anywhere.
There are displacement vectors.
at this
Position Vector is one where let me actually show
you the pictures just easier to explain with pictures so
position.
versus displacement
vector
and there's something called I have velocity Vector. We're going to look at the one
that we're doing is called a displacement vector.
so a position vector
Is something like this?
It's for example the line segment, OA.
But it is not.
Associated with some origin or as displacement Vector
is associated with a position in the from the
origin.
Okay.
And I'll tell you why I'm bringing that
up because what we do Vector Edition,
I want to we will displace a
vector to show you so we can understand what's going
on with the with the addition.
Anyway, what I'm going to do now is I'm going to use a
code from numpy. They'll allow
me to generate.
Like a hundred such points.
And that will give the appearance of a line.
Okay, so instead of doing this manually, I'm going to get rid
of these.
and I'm going to use
sequence of points to to you know
to give the impression of a line and here's the
code. So there's something called.
lens space linear space from numpy
so we go NP double in space.
And this takes three arguments.
the
so you're going to create a list of values, right?
the starting number
the ending number. Let's say 5.
and then the number of
values
that you will generate from 0 to 5. So if I say 100
then you'll get something, you know like this.
Small link criminals leading all the way to five. So that's 100
points.
That's for the egg. Now. Let's say this is for the x-axis. So I'm
going to go x equals NP that linear space.
0 to 5 and then the same thing for the y-axis.
And I can go.
back to ax Dot Plot
the plot argument can the plot method can either take a
single a scalar value or in this case a
list of values?
I'm going to go X and Y.
And I don't need to do anything else I please there we go. Yeah for
some reason when you when you are plotting with
lists of
With a list of what? Excuse me?
What the values that are lists you don't need to supply the additional
arguments, but there we go.
The way the reason we're able to see this line is because we have
100 points on this quarter 100x and
y's
now what I want to do is I want to show multiple vectors, but I don't want to use this
kind of code 5 created.
or of abstract the way the code so
there is this function.
That I've created it's called.
Vic so I'm going to get rid of these.
And it takes as argument.
the X and Y points
as a tuple so points will be at Tuple of XY.
Then the optionally the displacement along the X and
Y axis.
And all it's going to do is it's going to well start
at the on the x-axis. It will start at
the origin by default at zero.
It will start at the origin.
and
the stopping position
on the x-axis
And it will generate a hundred sequence of numbers just like we saw.
And then it will return the Tuple.
of
lists, so this will be a list. This will be a list and
there will be the Tuple but we'll convert this to
another by array. Why because what we want to perform the vector addition
and scalar multiplication.
And numpy object will allow us
to do that do that.
Then I have another function called Draw.
So this will create a linear space for a vector.
And this will draw the vector on the subplot.
So this will take as argument a vector.
which will be
a tuple where the elements are lists
so
Basically, we will be this V.
Will be something that looks like this.
Okay a list of values from 0.
0.01 Baba all
the way to for example 5
the same thing for the y-axis
So when we do math, we really just need.
One point on the x-axis one point on the y
axis.
That will give us for example somewhere there. But since we
want to draw the line, we also have to generate the points
leading up to that point.
So that's what this function does.
That's what this function does that we pass it to the draw function.
And of course we can we once we have
Generated the vector. We can
also displace it after having generated it.
So if I remove these displacement
values you can see it's just
This is going to be the list of X points on
the along the x-axis. This will be the points along the y axis.
And these are just additions to displace the vector.
Then I have this third function GP short for
get points.
I'll show you what this does in a second.
Okay, let me move it for now. Let's just keep things simple.
Now I'm going to create two vectors.
the sub one
which will be a vector.
at the point
zero
five
so I don't need to what once I have created these
functions. I have abstracted the way the numpy stuff
and I can just you know, you simple notation. So
V1 will be a vector from 0 to
5 V 2 will be a vector.
Let's make this one.
well
zero to negative 5
actually negative
Five, so this is five steps negative five
steps to the left.
and it will appear so we'll get a v
and then I'm going to draw these vectors. I'm going to go draw.
The argument has to be the first vector.
or V sub 1
and then V oops
T sub 2
and the draw function needs to
know.
which method to call so I'm going to use
they plot method of the ax object
the axis object.
And this is supposed to be 5.
Supposedly five. There we go.
Okay.
so I'm gonna I'm not the reason I set the x-axis to
go from negative 15 to positive 15 because I
don't want to
move away from this point
It's just easier that way.
Okay. So, let's see what vectorization does.
I'm going to create a third vector.
And the third Vector will be the sum of
the first two vectors.
so in order to do this
I need to grab.
the coordinates of the first vector
so this function
GP get points will well give me the points
of the first Vector which is 5 and 5.
and
the point of the second Vector so V sub 2
and the way this function works is a pretty straightforward.
Let me back here.
It will take the
the list
from the vectors remember a vector in this notebook.
Is a tuple of arrays?
So we'll take the array and the x-axis and
it will just grab the last element.
So the ending the ending number and the same thing for the y-axis and
then we will return and appearing.
Okay.
And then so I'm gonna add these points together.
And then turn it to a vector.
I'm gonna draw this third.
Now back here.
And you might be able to see it.
But you can see now that the size of this Vector is
double.
these two vectors
So I'm going to draw this in a different way.
I'm going to
not draw the third Vector for second.
And what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna align these
vectors.
I'm gonna stack them up on top of each other actually. So the first
Vector will go from 0 to 0 to
well 0 to 5. So be a vertical
line.
And I'm going to take the second vector
and draw it on top of the first vector.
So this will be
0 on the axis x
axis
okay, and
I'm gonna have to displace it here. So we
get this.
But I'm going to displace the second Vector. So let's also
use the colors here.
for colors I can use the
to which function did I added color?
See, so second Vector. I will make it
red.
And the first factor I will make it blue.
Okay.
yeah, these belong to the
draw function, sorry
And this will become blue.
Okay. Now I'm going to the I'm gonna displace the
red line by Five Points. I'm going to go.
Why displacement?
five
and then when I draw the Third
vector
I'm going to displace it five points across
the along the x-axis so we can see these two we
can see these vectors side by side. So X
displacement equals five.
There we go. So this is what vectorization does.
you will get
the well
This is what it means you get the it becomes
twice the length.
So I use this example because the examples, you know you I've seen
in books. We're not clear enough if I type here
vector addition.
You see examples like this.
Okay. Well, maybe this is clear enough.
or even this one
but by here, you know displacing it. I think it made it very very
clear.